hacia donde evoluciona la humanidad
hacia donde nos dirigimos como especie
desde una perspectiva tanto científica
como filosófica e incluso humanística
el tema de la evolución de la humanidad
es un tema que siempre me ha preocupado
la especie humana
desde todos los márgenes al igual que el
origen de la vida y el origen de las
especies
durante miles de millones de años toda
la vida en la tierra tanto la vida
animal como la vida vegetal han ido
evolucionando y desarrollándose
conjuntamente a partir de un mismo
origen
evolucionamos hacia la inmortalidad
concepto este como sabemos tan arraigado
y tan anhelado desde los orígenes de la
humanidad precisamente por el miedo la
angustia a la conciencia de la
mortalidad
o evolucionamos hacia el transhumanismo
partiendo del concepto del
transhumanismo como la búsqueda
de una nueva especie fusión de lo humano
con lo tecnológico creando una simbiosis
entre el hombre y la máquina entre el
hombre y la inteligencia artificial
personalmente pienso que ninguno de
estos conceptos es válido
la inmortalidad no existe y la raza
humana va a seguir siendo una raza
humana durante toda la eternidad lo que
así es una realidad es que cada vez la
longevidad es mayor
la esperanza de vida es mayor la
supervivencia es mayor y esto conlleva a
que las personas envejezcan cada vez más
envejecimiento que a diferencia de lo
que algunos dicen que hablan del
envejecimiento como una enfermedad no es
una enfermedad el envejecimiento igual
que la muerte son procesos evolutivos de
la vida y como tal hay que asumir los
que tenemos en común todos los seres
vivos todos los seres vivos tenemos en
común que estamos formados por átomos
materia inorgánica que se une formando
moléculas estas moléculas van formando
progresivamente todas las bases
nitrogenadas forman los glúcidos los
lípidos las proteínas
que son los constituyentes de toda la
vida
a nivel de evolución biológica
la vida empezó hace cuatro mil millones
de años la vida empezó por procesos
físicos y químicos donde la materia
inorgánica los átomos se unieron en
moléculas éstos dieron lugar a proteínas
como digo bases nitrogenadas y de salvas
entró gen hadas se crearon las primeras
células las células con un núcleo y
citoplasma las células eucariotas y a
partir de ellas se fueron creando luego
ya todos los organismos pluricelulares a
nivel de producción biológica todos
tenemos los mismos componentes como
estamos diciendo es decir todos estamos
formados por átomos el cuerpo humano
está formado por átomos somos materia
inorgánica sobre todo carbono hidrógeno
oxígeno nitrógeno y fósforo
todos los seres vivos estamos formados
por esos elementos esos elementos que se
van uniendo van formando células como
hemos dicho anteriormente es hacerlos
forman tejidos forman órganos y esos
órganos y esas células a través de la
replicación del adn van creándose de
nuevo continuamente
a nivel biológico podemos decir que de
acuerdo con las leyes de la
termodinámica sobre todo con la segunda
ley de la termodinámica en la entropía
el ser humano la evolución del ser
humano es la muerte la desintegración
debido al metabolismo hacia dónde
evoluciona la humanidad nos debemos
preguntar cuál será el futuro de nuestra
especie
seguiremos evolucionando como hicieron
nuestros ancestros qué influencia tiene
los avances de la tecnología sobre
nuestros organismos que son las
preguntas que nos podemos hacer muchas
de estas preguntas
la respuesta lógicamente pues es
especulativa incierta pero lo que sí
está claro lo que sí está claro es que
el futuro de la humanidad va a depender
totalmente del futuro de la medicina del
futuro de la medicina como una ciencia
que es ahora una ciencia
multidisciplinar que está integrada
tanto por la genómica la ingeniería
genética la nanotecnología la
inteligencia artificial y la robótica
todo esto llevándonos hacia una medicina
cada vez más avanzada hacia una medicina
personalizada y hacia una medicina
regenerativa medicina que veremos
implantarse a lo largo de las próximas
décadas en todos los países
civilizado
estamos yendo medicina hacia la
singularidad tecnológica
estamos entrando de lleno ya estamos
dentro de la tercera gran revolución de
la humanidad la revolución tecnológica
donde hay cambios disruptivos tremendos
y donde la fuente la materia prima
son los datos la información
transformada en datos datos tanto
estructurados como lo estructurados
estamos metidos dentro en medicina
dentro de la computación ubicua
estamos metidos en una medicina
totalmente conectada donde la
inteligencia artificial en la robótica
lo que hacen es mejorar los procesos
asistenciales mejorar la calidad
asistencial mejorar la eficacia la
eficiencia y la efectividad inteligencia
artificial y computación ubicua con gran
desarrollo de nanotecnología y con gran
desarrollo de aplicaciones como puede
ser esta que vemos sensores biométricos
a través de los cuales podemos seguir
perfectamente a los pacientes y viendo
sus signos vitales sin tener que
desplazarse a un hospital también tiene
gran influencia dentro de la medicina
del futuro y lo que estamos hablando de
inclusión de la humanidad la medicina
genómica la medicina genética y sobre
todo a través de las nuevas herramientas
como el cris per que lo que permite es
evitar corregir y cortar partes de las
moléculas del adn
eso nos permitirá quitar parte de
posibles enfermedades congénitas antes
de que el paciente nazca otro gran
avance en la ingeniería tisular con la
impresión 3d como podemos aquí ver son
modelos experimentales todavía pero que
la evolución está hacia la ingeniería
tisular y la presión 3d sobre todo con
células madre otro tenemos las bio
prótesis tenemos aquí por ejemplo los
ojos biónicos las prótesis articuladas
de extremidades donde mejoramos al ser
humano y le damos una posibilidad de
tener una vida prácticamente normal que
de otra manera estaría muy limitada a la
persona lógicamente son prótesis
biológicas inteligentes que se pueden
aplicar al ser humano
también la ingeniería tisular con las
células madre para hacer cultivos de
piel por ejemplo
tecnologías avanzadas como esta que
permite mantener corazones y mejorar las
técnicas de los trasplantes prolongando
el tiempo de isquemia evitando de esa
manera la aumento de mortalidad y la
viabilidad del injerto tenemos también
la posibilidad de crear órganos
sintéticos órganos artificiales como el
corazón para poder mantener a personas
que de otra manera estarían muertas
porque no tienen otra solución posible
como esta por ejemplo un corazón
artificial que pudo soportar este niño
con vida durante ocho meses hasta el
momento y que llegó un corazón donante y
le pudimos hacer el trasplante
con el órgano totalmente ajustado a su
vio como compatibilidad o como este otro
caso de pacientes con insuficiencia
cardiaca terminal que no podían no eran
susceptibles de realizar un transplante
cardíaco y hubo que implantarles un
corazón artificial total en el paciente
para poder seguir viviendo todas estas
son técnicas que se han desarrollado
gracias a la ingeniería biomédica y que
dan un poco la visión de hacia dónde va
la humanidad otro de los grandes avances
sin lugar a duda en la cirugía robótica
cirugía robótica que permite hacer
cirugías complejas hacer cirugías con
gran precisión e incluso poder hacerlas
a distancia como esta cirugía robótica
que en este momento se está haciendo que
es una cirugía de revascularización
miocárdica con un injerto de arteria
mamaria realizada
esta cirugía como vemos se puede hacer
con una gran precisión eso que están
viendo ustedes ahora es la arteria
mamaria que se ha abordado a través de
una incisión de dos milímetros a través
del tórax y se están esos brazos
articulados robóticos están diseñando la
arteria mamaria de la vena para poder
hacer luego la anastomosis a las
arterias coronarias en definitiva
estamos viendo que la integración de la
cirugía robótica la genómica la
nanotecnología y la inteligencia
artificial están potenciando la creación
no de una nueva raza humana sino de lo
que yo llamo los humanos
tecnológicamente mejorados no es que la
persona se vaya a convertir en un robot
no es que la persona se había convertido
en un cyborg es que estamos mejorando
tecnológicamente a los humanos
y para finalizar deciros que estamos
dentro de un cambio de paradigma un
cambio de paradigma donde tenemos una
gran responsabilidad social y esa
responsabilidad social es que todos
estos cambios tecnológicos disruptivos
poderlos llevar a buen fin y obtener un
bien público de manera que podamos
gestionar todo lo que estamos hablando y
lograr humanos tecnológicamente
mejorados pero con la filosofía de que
esa longevidad tenga años de vida
ajustados a la calidad acabó con mi lema
de la imaginación es el principio de la
creatividad para intentar que todos
aquellos que me escuchan lograr entre
todos que se fomente la investigación y
los trabajos multidisciplinares para que
de alguna manera se pueda lograr crear y
hacer práctica aquellas y aquellas
imaginaciones que pueda tener la
humanidad y que en un futuro sean
realidades
[Aplausos]